isn't there a law saying that you can't
get a medical marijuana card if you also
have a concealed carry permit basically
what you've got right now in the state
of Florida and actually it's a federal
requirement there's a form you fill out
scald a 4473 as soon as you buy a
firearm you fill it out one of the
questions on that form is do you
currently use marijuana if you check yes
to that question they cannot sell you
the gun really again it's a federal law
we still have it still a Schedule one
drug and until they change that that law
is not going to change a whole lot now
with that said Nicki freed here's the
new Agriculture Commissioner for the
state of Florida has and is going to
allow in the state of Florida for you to
carry your CCW you can carry concealed
permit and have an M MTC card which
means you're going to obviously be armed
okay so this will I'm sure there'll be
some there'll be some pushback it's like
everything else it's like listen you're
not well you're not supposed to be
drinking and shooting your gun when you
to ban alcohol is gonna encourage you to
use your gun game is not bingo different
different forms and that's so true
because and it's gonna make you
de-escalate a whole lot more than
alcohol exactly to escalate so looking
at looking at the process looking at
what's in place she's gonna push this
now we're working with her we agree with
this process we think that if you carry
a gun
hey listen even if you're a law
enforcement official and I know that
this does not sit well with a lot of
these guys but again they have a suicide
problem or challenge that allows with
that is developed within the industry
itself we just had a deputy who come in
to suicide and Pasco here with her
service revolver she's her husband was a
deputy and she shot and killed herself
and listen under any circumstances
that's not acceptable why would a young
she only been a deputy for five years
had a great looking family I don't know
the deputy personally but I knew that
the stresses that they go through on an
everyday basis and I talked to him about
cannabis most of them have such a
hardcore line on that under with regards
to being able to ingest cannabis that
they're like no no no no we're not gonna
do that so my next question is to them
so suicides okay as an alternative right
so how do we you know how do we curb
that again through education making
people understand if you go to if you go
to California right now it's funny
because it is legal there so even when
I'm standing with a group of people and
one of the guys pulls a joint out say at
a convention I immediately kind of stoop
my shoulders down hey hey hey you know I
have to catch myself because it's so
we're so trained right to do it this way
for the longest time out in California
we hardcore got into this originally
through a former police officer who saw
need hmm
the challenges are obviously this is a
cash based business so what happens is
when I drop off cannabis
we're picking up cash